et ces documents ont parfois une valeur
inestimable c'est l'objet de ce
quatrième et dernier épisode
regardez c'est un document que l'on
exposé peu sauf circonstances
exceptionnelles
son état de conservation est remarquable
quand on sait qu'ils remontent à trois
siècles
ses dimensions à mettre 50 sur 1 mètre
80 regarde tous les arbres on pourrait
presque compter en fait le nombre
d'arbres qui avait dans le parc de du
château d'anne est à cette époque là
alors la date tiens oui justement de
candidates 10 761 le 10 février
c'est magnifique c'est incroyable
regarde le détail des des fleurs ce
document est exceptionnelle à plusieurs
titres
de par sa taille de par son état de
conservation est également aussi par la
qualité de son exécution situe en
eure-et-loir le château d'anet tu est un
édifice renaissance commandé par henri
ii pour sa favorite la belle diane de
poitiers
après le château d'annette d'autres
documents sont remontés du sous-sol des
archives départementales merci alors ça
c'est honteux notariale c'est ça alors
qu'en 1892
voilà normalement on doit être à voilà
on a du parchemin ici sur la couverture
les là d'actes will à 2499 à 1506 voit
donc là on a une des plus anciennes
minutes notariales
donc on voit tout de suite la différence
de papier par exemple ou d'écriture
on voit aussi que celui ci a traversé le
temps mais avec un petit peu de
difficulté pendant très très longtemps
on est allés chez le notaire dès qu'on
avait un acte ou un contrat important à
à conclure a signé pour lui donner en
fait une une authenticité et une valeur
juridique qui soit reconnu ensuite en
cas de litige il faut quand même
rappeler que la plupart des gens des
paysans des bourgeois était illettré
donc le notaire lui était un personnage
savant qui savaient écrire qu'ils
connaissaient les lois une autre
surprise
une rareté étroitement gardées sous clé
un morceau de parchemin époque
mérovingienne
c'est la relique de menus lgv qui était
évêque de maastricht au 6e siècle et la
relique était un morceau de son vêtement
qui était conservé dans le trésor de la
cathédrale de chartres les archives
départementale d'eure-et-loir regorge de
véritables trésors
de quoi donner le tournis